hey guys Ryan right here and tonight I'm
gonna be watching some movie clips of my
most anticipated movie of the year
I'm excited watch these clips I hope
they stop here I hope they don't do some
spider-man to [ __ ] on us man but as far
as x-men Days of Future past goes I'm
loving everything I've seen about it's
got the intensity down it's it's dark
they seem like they're actually able to
combine all these characters into a
movie a cursive storyline with an N
sambal not just like hey we got
Wolverine again it's like they got a
real ensemble and it feels like they
have some good focus I'm excited for
this [ __ ]
alright first clip called you abandon us
what you to that treatment for my spine
affects my DNA you sacrificed your
powers so you could walk you know I lost
my vision ah dry your eyes Erik doesn't
justify what you've done
you have no idea what I've done I know
that you took the things that mean the
most to me well maybe you should have
fought harder for them if you want to
fight Erica I'd ask you a fight you are
by dint way you took her away and you
abandoned me
ah
what's going on we were supposed to
protect them Eric where were you Charles
you abandoned us all x-men Days of
Future past May 23rd radio pg-13 in
RealD 3d in large format theaters dude I
got lost in that [ __ ] I was really
[ __ ] hooked hardware jets started
going downhill and stuff it look weird
but seems like it really has the emotion
down you know I like how that was like
the clip did release because it's
showing you know this film is still
gonna have the [ __ ] great acting that
you want you bugged me right next clip
Mystique's attack or mystique attack and
stick-up tag [ __ ] hello thank you for
coming with this weapon there will be no
human collateral damage I turn it on the
system couldn't even activate it unless
[ __ ] alarmists oh cool oh it's
Jennifer Lawrence
Oh
stick it tack damnit Jennifer Lawrence
can move like that
nice [ __ ] eddie gordo Rebecca nice
that's awesome
oh she's sexy damn I would [ __ ] mystique
I really would
she is so [ __ ] high I wonder there's
porn where you can if there's porn where
you can actually see like you know
person [ __ ] mystique post that link
right next clip Wolverine meets Beast
this will be the second time he is
meeting beast for the first time is Ryan
a genius I like the things that look at
Norton man okay uh yeah what happened to
school are you a parent
sure so hope not haha your beast
whatever the sunglasses I guess you're a
late bloomer I don't know what you're
talking about them and that's Ashley so
where's the professor
it's no professor here are you stronger
Scott again sure there's not at least it
ah [ __ ] I love him as well we're in the
schools closed you need to leave
not until I see the professor there's no
professor here I told you that look kid
you'll know you're gonna be good friends
just don't know dia uh-oh
smash
yes Days of Future past third rated
pg-13 in will be 3d of March for meth
eaters it's even got the humor man these
clips are [ __ ] awesome because
they're just like a we're gonna give you
one hell of an entertaining feast I
cannot wait for this movie I'm praying
to God that when that final rotten
tomato thing appears if it's rotted nor
if it's a fresh tomato it's always a big
like thank God when it's like 89 percent
or something 90 so you know he starts
off at a hundred but it never stays at a
hundred day I was well [ __ ] worth it
I'm pumped and I am ready to let it out
you know I'm sorry
masturbation anyway if you like talking
about masturbation on camera subscribe
or if you just like what you experienced
alright here we go
shoutout time zpx this dude says he's my
number one fan
wells APX well well well most people
would just go come thank you that's
really kind of you I want you to prove
it to me do something stand out amongst
the crap prove that you are number one
avenge a show he made us a video well he
doesn't leave a few comments no
seriously we appreciate it but prove
yourself Karen Lopez specify that he was
a male that is not a woman you wanted to
shout out or he'll eat me mmm I like the
way you talk Karen like a better one I
think Karen is a girl's name though
what's going on baby
Diablo xxx two hundred thousand two
thousand my bad take two Diablo xxx two
thousand xxx
three that is the subtitle to that name
dude what is up Vin Diesel I knew you
were a fan of the channel how's it going
or Ice Cube I hope it's been diesel you
said you wanted to shout out so here it
is
Vin Diesel or Ice Cube either way you
are both six degrees separation for me
of Samuel Jackson you common a lot I
appreciate that it takes courage takes
character takes willing to go against
your fears
leave a comment I
is I think I'm so funny that's really my
biggest problem but that's also kind of
funny to me